what's up guys Greg here it's Super Bowl
Sunday and I'm alone in my apartment to
watch the trailers by myself and not go
to any parties anyway though on a bright
side there's a Gardens the galaxy vol 2
trailer out enough bullshitting around
[Music]
[Music]
tendu
baby Grenier dude what's up he says
welcome to the frickin Guardian only he
didn't use fricken
I try guys well I guess mantis isn't
gonna be an infinity war now now she's
probably still alive I mean you got Yan
doing here you got mantis you got nebula
I don't know much about these characters
honestly yeah you got baby Groot of
course I don't know as well as the other
original Gardens of the galaxy members
but I feel like the last trailers have
really been pumping us up for the you
know the returning characters of the the
original guardians of the galaxy I think
I'm saying his name right yondu I know
yondu was more of like a side villain
sort of in the first guardians of the
galaxy and now it looks like he's a
protagonist in this one you got other
characters in here as well you still
haven't seen Kurt Russell we still
haven't seen who's Sylvester Stallone is
there's still a lot more looking forward
to it I love the song choices in here
another thing I gotta add to the
cinematography like the way the first
one already looked amazing but the
cinematographer here looks even sharper
looks even clearer something we've come
to expect from a sequel to a big-budget
movie is they're gonna amp up the
effects even more and that's very much
evident here and I think rocket racoons
line that he semi shares with Groot
welcome to the freakin guardians of the
galaxy only he didn't use fricken can't
wait for every cool teenage girl walking
out of their local Hot Topic to be
wearing that shirt anyway guys there's
more trailers out subscribe to the real
rejects follow me on instagram and
twitter at the greg alba and i want to
give a shout out to god the real
guardian of the [ __ ] galaxy